hello everybody welcome to the
sixth aws gorgeous vps tutorial video
series
uh where we left off i was showing you
guys how you could run programs or
multiple programs
in your uh uh your either your aws or
bps
server but i ended with the caveat that
if you log out of your user account or
you close out of your terminal or you
lose an internet connection or something
uh what's going to happen is it's going
to hang up that script and everything's
going to you know stop
so the next thing that you need you can
do to conquer that
is use the command no hook which
literally stands for no hang up
uh so the way that you can do something
like that is you could say
for example noho python
um running one dot pi
and then you can put you know the
ampersand on there and now what that's
going to do is it's going to
run your running one dot pi in the
background
and as it does it's going to put the
output any output that it has
it'll put yeah it says right here uh no
hub ignoring all the input
and appending output to no hub.out so
it's also going to ignore any input i
give
here so now while that's running in the
background i can do anything else i want
go into python print high oops can't do
that but i can do this right
and so now i can do other things while
this is running in the background
now if we ls here oops sorry we got to
get out of
python so it's ctrl d the ls here
we can see now we have got this file no
hub dot out we can nano into
no hook dot out and
obviously there's nothing there right
now um
nano running one dot pi i can't remember
which one we ran
um let's see
let's try uh no
two dot pi let's see no hook
python running to that pi
i'll do that and hopefully that'll put
my output
nano i already forgot what it is
it's nano no hook
dot out yeah so it runs test two and
then we keyboard interrupted it
so now the problem here
with that is that obviously to do
anything else
uh we've interrupted the script and it's
unable to run
so what if you have maybe two three four
scripts
that you want to run how do you how
would you actually do that
well the next thing that you would do to
still utilize no hub and all this stuff
would be to do something like this so
you make a new file and we're going to
call this file command.sh
and in here we're going to we're going
to specify a bunch of stuff that we want
to do so
we'll do python running one dot
pi we'll run it in the background and
then and actually here's what we'll do
that and then python running two dot pi
we'll run that one in the background
uh wait yes sorry about that that was
something else not this
uh let me turn off my speakers
and so now command.sh will run that so
the next thing that we could do
is we could then say no hub um
then bash command.sh
and now that's going to run using bash
which is like our console basically it's
going to use our console to run
command.sh which contains those files
that we've already seen
and it's going to do that all
in the background here and with the idea
of no hub so if we
leave this window and actually log out
it won't it won't matter so anyway uh
those are just some more basics to
using no hub
and then also obviously command.sh with
bash to control it you don't have to
call it command.s h you call whatever
um and yeah so that should pretty much
cover
a lot of the basics of at least using
the amazon web services to run scripts
uh that's probably all i'm gonna do for
a little bit now uh with amazon web
services probably the next thing i'll
show you guys
is this python anywhere a real
interesting service
and it gives you pretty much everything
that you could have
here with aws plus it gives it's a
little bit easier it gives you a nice
gui that you can use and it still gives
you
you know your bash console and it comes
with python installed
and like it's i think it's got python
2627 and three three
pre-installed and it's kind of all like
i don't know probably like 200 modules
pre-installed so it's got all kinds of
stuff
again i'm not like an affiliate of them
um i'm just going to show you
at least what i think about their
website and stuff like that and and what
they've got so
pretty cool stuff coming up and
hopefully you guys have enjoyed and
maybe learned something
with aws or just even a vps you do all
the stuff that we did here
with any vps the only difference would
be obviously
if that vps doesn't come with python
pre-installed you would need to
install python but that's a really easy
procedure so
uh anyway that's gonna include this uh
video
and mini series at least for a little
bit i might show some other odd stuff
with aws
but pretty much you know the reason why
you're gonna use ec2
is really going to be to do processing
of some kind so maybe i'll show you guys
with like a database or something like
that
um and you can like you can host like
static websites and stuff on ec2
uh but it's not really the go-to place
if you want to host an actual like
website you'd want to use another vps or
something like that but
anyways hopefully it was useful for some
of you guys uh aws is totally free for a
year anyway so
might as well play around with it and
get used to the console
you can't really uh do anything too bad
anyway if you do you just restart and
play again so
pretty cool stuff it's good learning
experience so
anyways hopefully you guys enjoyed as
always thanks for watching thanks for
the support and the subscriptions and
until next time